[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we were we
went to our first UFC fight brag about
you guys are so lucky David was so happy
he legitimately said wow you look so
pretty today to you every day I know he
said he complements you a lot no he like
I said he genuinely meant it to so
different I was in them it was a state
of euphoria it was weird
I was like you know what this girl and
he kissed me on the cheek when we went
goodbye I was like dings David looks
super thin cuz you were doing some [ __ ]
like this it just made you look even ski
I recognized the ball brothers in that
photo though oh you guys this [ __ ]
buddy-buddy with the Paul brothers now
ha yeah best friends now damn man
there's good you did crack me up there
she was she goes look at these bubs are
right behind us we got better seats in
it yeah we're behind us that's crazy you
guys were freaking close though next to
Josh do mall Josh Jamal I was thinking
about you bastard he's the guy in the
Transformers movies it's like Osama Bart
yesterday like when you're watching a
Transformers movie and you're like oh
[ __ ] yeah robots are finding each other
and then they cut to the Marines it's
Josh Duhamel yeah like why are they
cutting the [ __ ] Marines I don't give
a [ __ ] you while you guys were doing
that [ __ ] UFC [ __ ] we were playing
jack box dude that's true I was honest
how was hell of fun you guys know it's
not that fun
here the trembling regretted his voice
here's the thing we had a great group
yep
and while you were Josh Duhamel we were
with real cool people and I believe it
wait because Nikki's watching this video
you want to say that just rub it all in
my face I was in bed all weekend sick as
[ __ ] but it's okay so what do you got
[ __ ] ecoli or something I was like
trying not to get anyway Mike she better
be sick she misses the sickest party
they have RJ what happened three people
know it was you don't need a lot of
people yeah we have to go to a UFC
though we have to like where when I was
just in the hallway and I heard Bruce
Buffer his voice I was already starting
to get crazy no I was like and then jail
is even telling like you're acting weird
I'm like yeah I know feels crazy in his
[ __ ] right now there was that
one chance that we had in Vegas too with
[ __ ] I forgot who was on the car but we
were so [ __ ] busy at that time it
felt like work to go to oh yeah I
remember that yeah yeah the only thing I
didn't like about it was the fans the
fans of the people don't really realize
how obnoxious and disgusting they were
do they have like affliction shirts for
sale they're at this at the stadium or
dude there was this guy next to me like
fur gut it's 90 degrees he had a sweater
vest on like I had like a college so you
were getting hot for him yeah and no and
the guy is just sitting there just doing
Joe Rogan commentary throughout the
whole [ __ ] high and behind Pence's
girlfriend yeah exactly so [ __ ]
annoying
that's armbar oh that's armbar - oh [ __ ]
you're Luxan bro see it's like how
talking about and then [ __ ] dude
spilled his beer on us oh yeah yeah yeah
why he's [ __ ] drunk like he's just
like that's just part of parcel of being
a live event my friend that's true I've
been NFL games like that happens
that's no matter where babies because I
enjoy the NFL a lot and I feel like
everybody's in that hype football pants
are annoying though everybody's in it
together
yeah stab that football bit Raiders game
that's not dodge that's it cuz I get
football it's a little different even
like a baseball game like it's kind of
boring there too I just go there eat hot
dogs to drink beer baseball is so
[ __ ] boring unless you're there live
like there live it's fun it's so pretty
it's so [ __ ] boring you can be okay I
like playing and I get bored just
waiting baseball it's pretty slow man
I'm not gonna lie like it's definitely
antiquated you see that like I can
understand why people aren't there for
the prelims because you're exhausted
after I was [ __ ] tired because my
butt was clenched the whole time you can
only watch something fights yeah also
the people start trickling in during the
main event yeah yeah dude in the
beginning fights it's I kind of half
empty so you guys did all of it like
from the piano we went like two three
hours after yeah there's positive like
10 fights you probably went out like
fight number five and then we watch like
three or four prelims and then we watch
the the real fights how's the opening
music thing life that's my favorite oh
[ __ ] I was going crazy so they don't
play like the UFC anthem until the
actual pay-per-view part so it's just
whatever fights and they just play a
little Johnny they did it but then they
did play the effect on me yeah yeah what
about when they do the walkout was it
longer in person like when it's not the
same as I did it pump you up live though
when they're coming out with the music
dude [ __ ] yeah dude I wish Wrestlemania
and all that [ __ ] was just people coming
out I wish they never even pulled you're
done yeah I don't even need them to
fight I just want them to keep coming
out to music like I would [ __ ] pay
for that that's what I want to do like I
don't want to actually fight I just want
to come out and then my I come out for
somebody on the other side
I want to walk out with the crew
everything of matching jackets and stuff
on you and check everything right and
then like the hype music I want to come
out to music and then I'm gonna come out
to another song on a different side of
it okay and you just keep coming out of
these six different outfits two
different songs they would be so hyped
okay now you're coming out in their row
I think it'd be good you have to turn
off the lights and let everyone jerk off
or something just so they have a release
because they're so hyped for something
that's pretty dope that'd be great
it's crazy even with like WWE that they
know that it's fake but it's something I
got more popular oh yeah even more
popular now when I was a little kid I
thought that [ __ ] was real son yeah I
knew it was a kid I thought it was all
yeah it's so theatrical
that's like a three year old i legit
thought people were getting their ass
beat oh wait maybe three miles to [ __ ] I
can't even remember at three I was like
three or five words like Hulk Hogan I
was like five years old for you like to
fight I remember a point where I thought
it was real Kenobi punch was like blood
and stuff you know she's you really
really bleeding I thought I thought
those were accidents like oh man like he
slipped up on that one I was the kid who
was like dude you tell me it's not real
or you said it's not real but I see
these guys take chairs to the head yeah
the guy was that [ __ ] I remember the
moment I questioned when it was real
being Zach moment so I was like Ricky
she fell off right at the stage he rolls
under he stays in there for two seconds
he comes out with the cut on his head
I'm like what wait what the [ __ ] just
happened you were smarter than me cuz I
would seem that shouldn't been like oh
man he must have been get the blood
pumping and I started bleeding I was a
[ __ ] idiot cut himself with like a
razor in there and he came out I was
like he [ __ ] what the [ __ ] and that
was it it wasn't even makeup it was like
he had a razor down there so the Bloods
real all glass and their socks and [ __ ]
and then they would cut their foreheads
with it well I know makeup cuz it looks
real it's real that's a carnies I want
to trick like a six-year-old and make
them because it's like the whole thing
is what it's real like it hurts it's
real pain it's real
and the [ __ ] they do is pretty amazing
like I want I watch the ladder match
SummerSlam 96 that [ __ ] was nuts dude
Razor Ramon versus Shawn like Liza Razor
Ramon you guys had a tooth pet
he always had a toothpick always threw
at the camera or whatever you guys have
a WWF game yeah I think the worst
character was Bam Bam Bigelow or a
Million Dollar Man like there were the
two weak ones no one wanted to be them
no one wanted to be the zoo slow I think
the two funniest characters in wrestling
history is the same person Cactus Jack
and what's it called mankind
Oh mankind's funny that guy called us
yeah these are the three most useless
homeless people that they somehow found
to get into the WWF OWP I'm sorry my bad
wait busy man kind of Maron out of what
I think so he just kind of looked at
Maher somewhere was he the one that had
all his hair in his face he he always
looks scary yeah yeah it was his brother
okay you know paint paint a senator now
okay - senator maybe that's what's so
crazy senator Kaine but very good I'd be
good no because there is a Senator Kaine
no suit Kaine is Tim Kaine that's not I
remember when Kane took his mask off and
I say we Yanks put it back on bro ever
seen Undertaker like in a movie was
scary and bourbon commando as a kid and
he's in that movie with Hulk Hogan and I
was like holy [ __ ] he's so [ __ ]
frightening even like lit like he was
frightened yeah he's like legit like six
foot six or some [ __ ] jheri-curl wasn't
always shiny - and he's got the bug eyes
like nothing else
dude he's always like yeah my favorite
[ __ ] though was when they did the two on
Tuesday and they would always have fat
ass dudes and they would sit on each
other I thought that was so funny I
remember this kid I hated his his name
was the 1-2-3 kid and I [ __ ] hated
that guy and now he's like a really
well-known wrestler I guess who was that
one heartthrob dude Oh Shawn Michaels
mine was the best he was like the best
athlete I ever saw when I was a kid I
was like holy [ __ ] the one with the back
kick he's one who stole all my honeys
dude he was he was like he was a rapist
he had the huge nono he was like no
Razor Ramon with the rapist
Breivik like the reference
with the rapist that Shawn Michaels was
a smooth guy that [ __ ] [ __ ] he had a
song he's like I'm a sexy boy it's just
me they look back it's like that means
not a good example for for a young boy
he had the Robin Williams chest hair in
the body and everything right exactly
but it wasn't a good example for young
boys as far as like something that could
actually get you late like don't do this
[ __ ] the juveniles like the buff like
WWE dudes growing up
okay so did you like them or not well
were you like those are those are like
dads yeah because you can have crushes
you know like I never liked way older
guys like like they were really ancient
for me because if I think there was that
age females but all doing wrestling I
would have liked that too they were hot
though the Divas Wow
remember that many female breasts Lacey
Keebler no I just remember we girl who
is that how do I know that name
Stacy Keibler look it up right now and a
picture of her ass will come out sounds
familiar
do you remember watching like my
induction all of [ __ ] and yeah and
Felicity was on that yeah the girls
played Felicity it's really pretty oh so
pretty and I had the biggest crush on
her and then I'm not even kidding you I
was on an airplane like [ __ ] three
weeks ago and you saw her I know I saw
Mighty Ducks Mighty Ducks on a screen
like next to me and I saw felicity and I
had I remember it like I had nostalgic
feelings up and I was like this [ __ ] is
nine years old I was like oh my [ __ ]
god I'm like what the [ __ ]
I thought pedophiles are made probably
that's well that's what nostalgia that's
the dark side nostalgia no we talk
something yeah that's true
nostalgic crush that we need Cooper
crush him cuz you could be 50 but the
shows she's still [ __ ] young in the
show till 12 pounds yeah so you're like
ha so you at that age to stop you gotta
stop but you can't and you can't resist
cuz when you watch it you become 12
again that's why you can't watch Mighty
Ducks anymore dude don't you even try oh
did you see a Goldberg recently Colburn
what does he lays it mighty that's the
the hockey one right the [ __ ] go the
fat guy yeah
crazy really you know yourself at [ __ ]
meth had finished [ __ ] he looks bull
this [ __ ] dude the machine isn't [ __ ]
bro not even an exaggeration like he
always the freckled fat kid in every
movie he was the hero in the fat Mexican
all the fat Mexican looked like he could
be a fat tallien dude did you guys know
Betty the JLo so I'm trying to know but
no no Benny the jet from this is bombard
I've had it out of I I know the karate
guy oh hey the jet from the Sandlot yes
Betty the main kid Benny oh I thought it
was just Benjamin Rodriguez oh no no I
was the jet now he's known as the jet oh
I don't know so fun all these kids are
like these [ __ ] old but they taught
me to he's got like aggravated assault
charges like [ __ ] him and him and a
bunch of he was a firefighter him and a
bunch of his friends like the some guy
was in the neighborhood like on
Halloween
I like the satellite they grab the guy
and beat the [ __ ] out of them because
they thought he was putting candies in
the apples room okay so the guy we're
talking about Coley Cole Ken
he went through a rough time kid okay
like you know those Mexican clowns that
they're all be look wait wait where did
he get caught oh I [ __ ] you not
there's a bump there's a bump that looks
exactly like that whenever I take the
dogs out where it's from Ben he he talks
to me as if we're already friends and
there's always like girls there and he
says that's my wife that's my girlfriend
and he's like a player ask him about my
T does I will that looks exactly like
them dude I'm not gonna believe you
because you see white cars and then you
remember them as yellow yeah why can't
you believe him when this guy was a meth
head it's actually very possible
that pool looks like 60 the city is a
weird place yeah dude why is that do you
think this city just makes people
[ __ ] crazy
there's so many people that talk to
themselves I think there's a lot of
people I also think that opioids and
[ __ ] it's all kind of nuts right now
yeah
like nobody's really talking about it
but it's like crazy that's true like
fentanyl and [ __ ] like like people
prescription drugs lasing like what they
think they're buying xanax and it's got
a fentanyl in it it's killing like 150
150 people a day or no what is that
knowledge I don't know it's uh it's some
some kind of thing we're like just a
couple just like just even smelling it a
little bit a little bit of it can kill a
200-pound man like it's crazy
well are they lacing it like in
prescription drugs or is it people are
taking it illegally street drugs [ __ ]
potent like that uh yeah so like kids
and universities are buying the [ __ ]
like or wherever but it's popular there
and in universities and they're buying
it for like say 20 bucks a pill or
whatever five bucks a pill and then
they're taking it and then they're just
not waking up you know the other way
people get hooked is they get on
prescription and then they start getting
it reduced but they're hooked and then
they have to go out and do heroin and
[ __ ] that's the amount of [ __ ] right
there
damn I just want my kid to be a [ __ ]
huge dweeb though right I mean like they
don't have any interest in any of it no
these are they take adderall and stuff
but that's not add weed though what do
you mean they got like dweebs relish it
like he's right this drug for sure yeah
oh really it's hard to escape all that
and in the opioids that are actually
people getting hooked it's middle age
and above people it's not like young
people well I'm not talking about it no
it's young people do Ford Christian kid
you know like one of those kids that
just have no interest in doing any of
that stuff so like I've uh I have a
friend who has a kid now he's a little
dweeby ass [ __ ] kid
guys straight arrows but a part of me is
like don't want my kid to be like that
but to say I do
because there's his moral compass is
very straight it's this this that kid
also sounds like here's how many friends
he does his friends are just like him oh
really yeah so he has his own group of
morally straight friends and I'm like I
want my kid like that but at the same
time I can't because like if my kids
like that he won't be able to take me
cuz I'll bully ammo oh yeah I can't like
that Punk is a sin video yeah because
like I want to be able to like go back
and forth with my kid you know dude I
think it's kids like that who end up
getting [ __ ] over the hardest cuz
because we all we always think of them
as being so straight now that as parents
you don't think you have to do anything
and then that and that's how they least
look maybe but his parents are pretty
hands-on and they had a stay-at-home mom
so his mom and him are like best friends
so about pressure though what if it's
like it's like oh he's the perfect kid
so then he's got the pressure would be a
perfect kid and he's [ __ ] Poppins
antics and [ __ ] it's weird I wish you
guys could meet them because they're
like I'm trying to find holes to trust
people
well that's it let's say one of his
homies because I think I have a really
straight moral compass let's say uh one
of his homies gets jumped does he back
him up he doesn't live in an area like
that at all but let's say his home he
gets it you can I'll try to test his
street code to there's no street code
see to me he is he's a snake I will say
this felt like [ __ ] snake he's like
one of those kids like man like I look
at this kid that I'm like that you are
such an amazing person because always
amazing he's like at this age he already
cooks for his parents he tells his
parents everything whether he does
something bad wrong or whatever and he
called his mom buddy goes hey like I did
this like I just wanted to talk to you
about it can you help me through it
that's the type of relationship that
they have great kid he is now in college
Oh failure to launch
apparel you're talking about a colleague
uh-huh my guys like your age like he's a
kid well he's one of our friends now
like you're proud of this like guy who's
like a year younger than you in 1920
unbelievable we're all about bro he's
[ __ ] 18 yeah so like the kids I have
this super open relationship with his
parents doh I see and I'm like how the
[ __ ] I also always asked him is like
both their kids like that so how the
[ __ ] did you get that cuz usually one of
the [ __ ] up what has to be well someone
they were raised with love
I can't be that simple I don't believe
like the mom I think that's a huge part
of it no way
patients love reasoning there's like
they're super a lot of people lack I
believe like when he had his first
girlfriend and told his mom like hey I
you know this is where all I like and I
want her to be my girlfriend like are
you okay with me having a girlfriend now
but I'm like you know they find out
after right but that parents probably
set up a good communicating environment
like that's what I'm saying it's wild so
like I see that type of stuff and I'm
like do I want that type of kid who want
to keep with the leaf dangerous I would
love to have that type of kid but with
my personality type I don't think I
would bring that out of the kid probably
know I didn't depends on the parents
your kids lighting a house on fire and
he's gonna tell you that somebody else
did it she did it because I use expect
the most polite kid I've ever seen as
history awesome it's crazy you know I
talked to KP but it seemed like how am I
gonna replicate this in another kid if
we have another kid like five how are
you that's true because some kids all
not some but every very example that I
witnessed like in my nephews and nieces
like all nine of them the personalities
are so [ __ ] different even from the
same parents so you're taking Tiff's
credit from her and saying it was just a
genetic roll the dice I like it yeah
yeah hear that - [ __ ] it
[Music]